This next story is not the most important
story, but it's the epitome of the petulant
child that is the president of the United
States.
There is this tradition and you know, I don't
care about tradition for the sake of tradition.
There's a tradition where for the last 40
years, presidents will come back to the White
House during the next administration and their
portrait will be unveiled by the then president.
NBC News is now reporting that Donald Trump
is refusing to do this for Barack Obama.
And I have to tell you, it kind of makes sense.
Donald Trump has spent the last couple of
weeks accusing Barack Obama of committing
the greatest political crime in the history
of the United States.
He's dubbed it Obama Gate.
It's totally bogus.
It's nonexistent.
But when you accuse a former president of
a crime, you're probably not also going to
then invite them to the White House to unveil
a painting of them.
Now, I don't care at all about formalities.
I don't care about faux bipartisanship.
But this is one of those things where you
just expect presidents will act in a certain
way.
Here is Barack Obama welcoming George W. Bush
to the White House for his portrait unveiling.
And I'm not normalizing Bush.
I'm not rehabilitating Bush.
Bush.
The Iraq war was a disaster, but they were
able to be in the same room with each other.
Obama and Bush.
Similarly, here's George W. Bush welcoming
Bill Clinton back to the White House for the
unveiling of his portrait.
And again, I don't care about these ceremonies
in a concrete sense.
I recognize the signal it sends that listen.
Republicans and Democrats.
This is about elites versus the non elites.
It's about neo liberals and non neo.
Look, I get it.
I understand that this is not about ceremony
because Trump is not saying let's do away
with this pointless waste of time.
We're in a time of crisis.
A party about a portrait is in bad taste.
That's not what Trump is doing.
If he were doing that, I might actually respect
him for doing it.
Trump just hates Obama.
Trump is threatened by Obama.
Trump has spent much of his presidency trying
to either undo everything Barack Obama did
or take credit for the things Obama did that
he likes and wants to be praised for.
And he has publicly accused Barack Obama of
being a criminal.
So this is a farce.
This is not about breaking with tradition.
It's about being a global laughingstock.
This is about Trump being the ultimate trigger
arable snowflake while he pretends to be the
ultimate alpha male.
And this is also about hypocrisy, because
Republicans have claimed for decades they
are all about tradition.
They are about doing the things the way that
we used to do them.
They are about returning to this vaguely described
prior way of life that they love.
Whether it's about norms and conventions and
tone or all of this other B.S., it does very
little to help people who are struggling to
feed their families.
There is no doubt, but here's just a stupid
opportunity to do it.
Just do the tradition.
Do the tone that you claim to love.
But no.
Instead, Trump is publicly accusing Barack
Obama of the worst political crime in the
history of the United States.
Despite being unable to actually name what
that crime is because there was no such crime
and he is not going to do this totally triggered
snowflake.
Pathetic.
Embarrassing.
The world continues to laugh.
And this is what we've got for four more years
unless we all do what we need to do in November.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We will take a quick break.
Remember Monday, Memorial Day, one day membership.
Special.
Huge membership.
Special Beautiful membership special.
Historic membership special.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
You'll get an email from me on Monday with
instructions on how to take advantage of
this
one day discount.